in life and death Israel's occupation
decides the fate of
Palestinians it's been nearly 2 years
since Mesa and her husband last saw
their
son Sone was a 23 year-old living in
nablo Who Loved
motorbikes he became a member of the
Lion's Den a group made up of Youth
rebelling against the
occupation he died in an armed
confrontation with Israeli soldiers 2
weeks later they received a letter
saying the body had been confiscated by
Israel all they had to bury was his hand
a bag and his partially burnt
ID it's only when he died that we
discovered he was part of the resistance
none of us knew I went to the hospital
and his friend told me my son was dead I
wanted to see his body but they said it
was taken
away a symbol public funeral was held
but the pain is real the family were
told that if this man now buried here
had at the time given himself up the
remains of their son would have been
returned now this policy of withholding
bodies and using them as bargaining
ships has existed since the creation of
the state of Israel actually it was
inherited from the British mandate but
it's only since
2015 that it's
intensified it's a policy that Jews
fighting against the British presence in
Palestine deed at the
time hundreds of bodies had been
confiscated since the occupation of the
West Bank started in
1967 before they kept only the bodies of
Hamas supporters or someone who carried
out an attack then the Israeli cabinet
decided to keep all the bodies
regardless of political
affiliation and sometimes the reason of
death can be obscure all nisin and nidal
Musa know is that their 15-year-old son
Muhammad took his father's car an
evening in December
2021 a couple of hours later this video
already on social media shows the car
after the teenager rammed it into a
checkpoint and Muhammad is standing
there a soldier injured on the
ground
we live under occupation you cannot
figure out what triggers your child he
always follows what's happening on his
mobile phone I don't know what affected
him exactly they killed him anyone they
suspect of
anything immediately maybe they
interrogated him first I don't know how
many hours was he held was he tortured I
don't know so many things n had a grave
m to give closure to her youngest son
who was asking after his brother but for
her closure will only come when the body
of her son is laid to rest and that's at
the will of Israel's military
occupation abdulhamid Al jazer naos